après 2018 2019 aussi réserve de
nombreux événements ont parlé du sport
hier la culture sera au rendez vous
également cette année mélanie poquet
bonsoir ça vous êtes allé piocher dans
la programmation des salles de
spectacles environnantes à quoi doit-on
s'attendre
déjà le premier rendez-vous grégory
c'est un texte bouleversant qui a été
porté sur scène vous n'aurez pas ma n
est écrit par antoine leiris alors
d'abord c'est un post facebook que le
journaliste écrit après la mort de sa
femme hélène au bataclan il en écrira
par la suite un livre adapté sur scène
par benjamin biya qui est aujourd'hui
interprété par raphaël personnaz et
c'est à découvrir un versailles les 17
18 et 19 janvier
je dois rejoindre melville qui se
réveille de sa schiste
il va prendre son goûter
comme tous les jours
[Musique]
et je vais jouer avec lui comme tous les
jours et toute sa vie ce petit garçon
vous fera l'affront d'être heureux et
libre à 2010 9 être aussi l'occasion de
fête un anniversaire le 51 gospel passe
cette année un quart de siècle
et oui un anniversaire célébré là aussi
au mois de janvier c'est à la ferme de
bel ébat 25 ans de partage autour du
negro spiritual du gospel urbain et du
rythm and blues alors en 25 ans grégory
plus de 120 concerts en région
parisienne principalement mais aussi
jusqu'à stockholm stockholm pendant ce
sursaut sur scène 70 chanteurs huit
musiciens
extraits
oh
il y a
bah
deux rendez vous donc au mois de janvier
sur le reste de la saison
alors pourquoi ne pas se rendre à
l'espace fibre noire et des clés souvent
à ceux des clés sous bois là vous
pourrez découvrir la dernière création
d' alexis michalik intra muros avec son
chéri c'est quand même edmond alors je
ne peux pas conclure son site elle est
tête d'affiche dans le désordre jane
birkin à montigny-le-bretonneux monte
manu payet et arthur h hae lanco
christophe alévêque à maurepas feu
chatterton attrape ou encore celle à à
plaisir je sais pas vous rigolez mais
pour moi ça va être très difficile de
choisir
effectivement c'est en ces grands
enfants on les retrouve également dans
votre émission le 7-8 culture mélanie a
retrouvé tout à leur merci pour cette
chronique